I have to be really careful what I say
here in my opinion the last two to three
years was very orchestrated they created
this problem and so they had to bring in
a solution the solution was a passport
passport's freedom of movement what that
essentially enables is a certain type of
digital ID it's a digital infrastructure
which is now already in place and now
once they control your movement with
this already existing infrastructure
they can now bring in a Central Bank of
digital currency we already have the
passport all you have to do is just add
another section we've got domestic
passport we've got travel passport oh
and now you can have your Central Bank
digital currency passport whereby you
can also add some form of social credit
score so if you say the wrong thing or
you like the wrong thing on social media
or you have these inappropriate
conversations and it goes public well
then they can just lower your social
credit score so the last two years
created a problem and it allowed a
digital ID infrastructure already to be
created so that Central Bank digital
currency can easily just swoop in